[Music]
you're on the trail of a werewolf that's
been terrorizing your town after months
of detective work you've narrowed your
suspects to one of five people the mayor
the tailor the baker the grocer or the
carpenter you've invited them to dinner
with a simple plan you'll slip a square
of a rare werewolf antidote into each of
their dinners unfortunately your pet
goat just ate four of the squares and
you only have one left
luckily the remaining square is 50 grams
and the minimum effective dose is 10
grams if you can precisely divide the
square into fifths you'll have just
enough antidote for everyone you'll have
to use a laser cutting tool to cut up
the square every other means available
to you isn't precise enough there are
eight points that can act as starting or
ending points for each cut to use the
device you'll have to input pairs of
points that tell the laser where to
begin and end each cut and then the
laser executes all the cuts
simultaneously it's okay to cut the
square into as many pieces as you want
as long as you can group them into ten
gram portions but you can't fold the
square or alter it otherwise and you
only get one shot at using the laser
cutter the full moon is rising and in a
moment someone will transform and tear
you all apart unless you can cure them
first
how can you divide the antidote into
perfect fifths cure the secret werewolf
and save everyone
when it comes to puzzles that involve
cutting and rearranging it's often
helpful to actually take a piece of
paper and try cutting it up to see what
you can get if we cut B F and D H we'd
get fourths but we need fifths maybe
there's a way to shave a bit off of a
quarter to get exactly one-fifth cutting
B e looks good at first but that last
cut takes off a quarter of a quarter
leaving us with a portion of three
sixteenths just smaller than a fifth and
not enough to cure a werewolf what if we
started with B e instead that would also
give us a quarter and is there a way to
shave just a bit more off both D G and C
H look promising if we make one more cut
from A to F we may start to notice
something with these four cuts from B to
e d 2g f - a + H - see we've got four
triangles and a square in the middle but
the pieces that make each triangle can
also be rearranged to make a square
identical to the middle one this means
that we've split the antidote into
perfect fifths what's interesting about
this sort of problem is that while it's
possible to solve it by starting from
the geometry it's actually easier to
start experimenting and see where that
gets you that wouldn't be as viable if
the square had saved 24 cut points but
with just eight there are only so many
reasonable options you secretly dos each
of the townspeople as the full moon
emerges in the sky and just as you do a
terrible transformation begins then just
as suddenly it reverses your
measurements were perfect and the people
and animals of the town can rest a
little easier
but wait there's more the carpenter
tells you his werewolf curse began in a
nearby afflicted village there the
werewolves can be identified because
they always lie while the humans always
tell the truth you visit the village and
question all 100 inhabitants every one
of whom says at least one of us is a
human you know that there is at least
one werewolf in the village so how many
of the total are also werewolves this
bonus riddle comes courtesy of our
sponsor brilliant they start with simple
questions that build your intuition ramp
up to problems that entice you and then
help you develop different ways of
solving problems that were previously
out of your grasp to hone your capacity
to think critically visit brilliant org
slash ted-ed
and the first 833 of you to use that
link will get a 20% discount off the
annual subscription